so thank you to the organizers for
inviting me to speak
here uh
so I want to talk to you today about
um all what those handouts get around a
little bit
um so I want to tell you about a fairly
General approach for uh positivity
problems Okay so we've seen that
positivity problems are sort of an
important part of geometric complexity
Theory and what I mean by positivity
problem is that we have some uh
structure coefficient arising in
Geometry or representation
Theory uh that's known to be non-
negative um through the the geometry
representation Theory like chronical
coefficients or plethysm coefficients or
for instance the multiplicity of an
irreducible representation in the uh
coordinate ring of the orbit closure of
the determinant so these are some uh
coefficients we're interested in better
understanding and we want some efficient
way of computing these these non-
negative coefficients so from the
complexity theoretic perspective what a
natur the natural question asks is for a
Sharp P formula for these
coefficients
um from the algebraic combinatorics
perspective uh we sort of want maybe a
little bit more than that so we also
want some nice combinatorial object that
counts this coefficient like a tableau
with a certain satisfying some special
conditions and then we probably also
want that formula to be sharp P but the
notion in algebraic combinatorics is not
a is not a precise
one I think sort of a lot of algebraic
combinatorics is actually built around
studying these positivity questions
Shubert intersection coefficients uh QT
QT Costa polinomial or something that's
related to what I'll talk about today
so I want to um just give you a
brief uh overview of what I know about
uh solving these
problems
so the way I think of this is there's
sort of there's sort of a spectrum of
approaches on on the one side we
can
um there are basis theoretic
methods okay and the other side I'll
write Tableau Comon in
Torx okay so so I think of these here as
as these are sort of more
structured or this these are less
structured okay so basis theoretic
methods what I mean is maybe we have
some uh say module for the symmetric
group and we want to decompose it into
irreducibles we want the multiplicity of
some irreducible representation in that
well instead of just trying to get some
combinatorial formula for those
coefficients we could ask for something
stronger which is for a basis for this
module
such that subsets of this basis actually
decompose it into irreducibles okay give
so subset of this basis actually spans
an
irreducible subm module and from the
labels of this basis you can read off a
combinatorial formula this is almost the
best solution you could hope for and
sometimes you can do this so there are
techniques using what's called canonical
basis canonical bases C un lustic bases
where you can produce very nice bases
sometimes uh uh their sort
of less fancy methods using monomial
bases or something like this
um okay so maybe on the other side of
the spectrum there's just sort of
playing around with Tableau
combinatorics and words um and what I
want to talk to you about today uh fits
sort of in the middle here is theory of
uh non-commutative sure
functions
uh of fine and of Sergey fomine and
Curtis
green and there so there's a funny thing
here which is that uh so over on this
side when you're when you're sort of
demanding more uh for your solution to
these to these problems you would I mean
it's more so it's in some sense it's
harder to do but but at the same time it
could be easier because what can happen
is if you sort of specify if y exactly
the right uh amount of structure you
want to put on this solution then maybe
it will be unique and then it's easier
to find okay so that's that's one of the
games that you that you play here is
that uh there's there's sort of too many
weird things you can do with Tableau uh
to try to give you combinatorial formula
but if you maybe demand more out of your
solution out of your combinatorial
formula then maybe it will be easier to
find okay so now for the remainder of
the talk I'm going to
uh first I'm going to tell
you about the platic
algebra so this is sort of where this
this uh this General approach of
non-commutative Shure functions
originated in the work of shen lasu and
chut and B on the platic
algebra uh and then after that I'm going
to sort of give you the general outline
of how this Theory goes and then I'm
going to give three
applications
all right so so we'll let
you
uh be the
free non-commutative
algebra in generators U1 U2 and so
on and and we'll sometimes write
um just a in place
of uh U sub a so so so there there's a
basis for this this
algebra uh U there a
basis of words okay just words in the
positive integers these form of basis
for this algebra multiplication is just
concatenation of
words
okay all right so we're going to be
interested in certain quotients of this
algebra so the platic algebra is one
such quotient so the platic
algebra the quotient of
U uh by the can equivalence
relations
okay which are the following so for
letters uh a b and
c um there the following uh let's say
we'll break them into four four
different
relations I guess I've got
to can you guys see
this okay so so what to how to think
about these relations so um so we just
want to think that we can swap two
letters A and C in the presence of a
third letter that whose value lies in
between the
two
so a good way to understand
um uh this algebra or actually any any
quotient of view by binomial relations
Is In terms
ofc uh they're just integers so positive
integers so I'm I'm just using this the
this is really U sub a u subc u
subd are you going to tell us a little
where this comes from
uh was planning to why is this a
reasonable set of relations to impose um
I'm going to tell you in a minute how
it's related to the rsk algorithm is
that uh will that help you yes um all
right so the
um so so to understand this algebra um
we're going to define a graph that
encodes the relations essentially so
the equivalence
graph uh is the
graph so we have a Vertex
set will just be the set of all
words
maybe later we can take some natural
subset of words but for now let's just
say the set of all words and then we'll
say that
VW is an
edge between two words if uh V and
W uh
differ by a single
application of uh can equivalence
relation so let me just clarify what I
mean by this with an example
so so let's look at uh the word 15 uh 2
43 and let's find all its neighbors in
this canu equivalence graph okay so if I
look at the first three
letters what can I do so these relations
say that I can swap one and five because
this two is here it's a sort of in lies
in between one and five it's witness in
to the fact that I can swap them okay so
I'll draw an edge there so I can go to
51 2
43 uh what about the next three letters
5 2 4 okay so four lies in between five
and two so I can swap the five and the
two get 1 2 5 4
3 uh the last three letters 2 4 three I
can swap the two and the four because
the three lies in the
two and sometimes it's convenient to put
labels on these edges uh that that tell
you sort of which three letters you did
the swap the the C equivalent at okay so
so the natural way is is to sort of put
the position of the middle letter that
you used so though this one be labeled
two three and
four uh on your handout that have you
has everyone gotten a hand out
yet so so that first figure is um I
should I should take one so I
can okay so um this first figure is is
the entire can equivalence graph on uh
permutations of
four and
the components of this graph are called
canu equivalence
classes uh and I just want to
remark
um uh the relation to the rsk algorithm
so if you don't know what the rsk
algorithm is you can take this as a sort
of a partial definition um but so on on
your handout you see these
components okay of your uh can
equivalence graph and
the rsk algorithm so it takes a
word so you're always telling with a
finite that's there's a finite number of
Ed that's what I was missing
before no it's infinite I mean it's it
doesn't
hurt this is just what I've shown you is
just some piece of the conu equivalence
gra right um but yeah I mean so so it
doesn't we can work with a finite number
it doesn't really matter
yet so
um it's like the difference between
working with symmetric functions in
infinitely many variables or finally
many that that's what it will come down
to
um so so we have our rsk algorithm that
takes a word w produces two Tableau of
the same shape the insertion Tableau P
of w and the recording Tableau Q of w
okay and in terms of this graph what the
uh the P of w it's like two coordinates
so the P of w tells you which component
you're in it it naturally labels these
components and the Q of w tells you
where you are uh inside the component
so P of
w
labels
components the insertion of right that's
the insertion
yeah yeah so this will be
insertion and this will be
record and the the recording Tableau uh
let's say just tells you where you
are in the component
or the same as a can equivalence
class okay and actually you can you can
um rephrase the the insertion algorithm
as a specific way of of walking inside
this graph so you start with some word
you you walk by some special set of
edges until you get to a special vertex
inside that
component uh namely the row reading word
of of the insertion
Tableau that's it's sort of one way to
think about the rsk
algorithm um so I gave a similar talk to
this at
UCLA and eigor Pac asked me
uh why should I care about the platic
algebra if I know about the rsk
algorithm and actually that's very good
question so the answer is is basically
you shouldn't actually so the rsk
algorithm if if you know the rsk
algorithm it tells you kind of
everything you want to know about the
platic algebra and more actually um
but somehow that's the point of of this
approach uh of non-commutative sure
functions so what's going to happen is
we're going well I'm going to sort of
tell you how uh this approach Works in
some general quotient of view but
um so it will be positivity of what
positivity of
what where is
this you're talking about the title or
yeah so
what um it's it's going to be um so so
one result that comes out is uh sort of
a combinatorial formula for certain QT
Costa polinomial for
instance maybe maybe can you get a
little bit more details about the
connection to the
RS so I mean I wonder I mean the rsk you
have to work then you insert it you
build up this two to F this so but I
would like I mean this should be a part
this so what is the connection exactly
you would start with the
work then you
would insert uh the next can you give an
example just one uh it's it's okay it's
not so easy to say exactly the precise
relation but um we can do an example so
let's insert this um p
of5 2 4
three okay so this is going to be I'll
start with one five and then two bumps
the five yes and then four and then
three bumps the
right from
above you bump from above into the yeah
uh from I start from the top okay so so
how did this Implement some conu
equivalence relations well what happens
is when
you when you have
let's let's start with you didn't do Q
what you didn't do Q I didn't do Q I'm
just talking about P right now uh so
um uh so okay so the when you insert a
new letter into a
tableau uh
basically you can you you can realize
the insertion into a single row by just
doing a um some sequence of C
transformations in sort of three
consecutive letters
um so if I have like one 35 and then I
insert the four then I can realize the
bumping of four into this 135 with a can
transformation at
354 and then at sort of the next three
letters and then what I'll end up with
with is basically a letter so either
this four will go on the end of the row
in which case I don't do anything or it
will turn
into uh something where I have a letter
followed by an increasing word and then
I do the same thing with that letter to
the next row and so on but I wonder if I
have this Tableau do I have to think of
it as a long word by just concatenating
the r yes yes that's how you should
think of it in this context yeah yeah
okay then these local these rules kind
of model what you do when you do the rsk
that's right that's right yeah but it's
it's somehow less information
so so over there we should read this is
going from right to left that you start
with in your Tau you start with the
thing on the right and you want to move
it to the left is that what where are
you pointing to so your newth
equivalence relations right yeah I want
the five to be at the end of the row if
it's going to be on that row so I would
want the C that's like the second one
the C has to has to has to um get pushed
to the end yeah
so so you can do this with
several yeah
Transformations um but but some okay so
the what the platic algebra is doing is
it's it's only telling you when two
things have the same P Tableau and then
it sort of forgets the rest of the
information uh somehow the point of the
approach that I'm going to tell you
about is that you can extend this
approach to quotients of U where there's
no analog of rsk but but there is some
analog of the platic algebra
okay
um okay so here's
um the general foaming
green
theory of non-commutative sure
functions uh so let's
define uh let's say for a
word w of length
n uh The Descent set of
w is just the set of
indices um from one up to
nus1 such that
wi is greater than wi +
1 so those two consecutive letters where
you go down okay I'll I'll show you an
example in a second all right um the
other thing I
need uh is what's called guess's
fundamental uh quasy symmetric
function
okay so this is denoted uh Q uh sub
let's say so it depends on some descent
set um but I'm going to so I'm going to
write it like this so this is in um now
commuting variables X1 up to xn uh or
let's say infinitely many commuting
variables so I I have two sets of
variables where working with I'm working
with these U's and I'm also going to be
working with commuting
XI okay
um so this is defined as
follows so this is some
degree n a homogeneous
polinomial uh in let's say infinitely
many uh commuting variables uh and I
missed the important condition so um if
if I have J belonging to theet of w this
implies that I have a strict inequality
of the indices
here so this is not a symmetric function
in general but it's a convenient
building block for symmetric functions
okay so so I mean one if we want to
write down a
symmetric function um then it's going to
take us infinitely many monomials but
with quasi symmetric functions I only
need Finly many to write down some
interesting symmetric
functions we'll we'll see more about
sort of why these are useful but this is
kind of a standard tool in a symmetric
function Theory you just write down a
real small one yeah I'm going
to
um yeah so so for example
Le uh if I
take mon what is a pol function you
think any
monom
this the example that we can ask um okay
so so say Q sub
um uh one
2 uh of X is just equal to e uh 2 of
X the elementary symmetric function of
degree
2 because uh whoops sorry this is
um uh so I I've suppressed let let me
this actually depends on N but I've sort
of suppressed it from the left hand side
here so let me write um let's say the
cense set of 3 2 1 will be the
elementary symmetric function of degree
3 okay because this this strictness here
says that all these have to be distinct
these indices have to be distinct that's
exactly an elementary symmetric
function okay if I take an if I take on
the other hand if I take some increasing
word here 1 2 3 this gives me my
homogeneous symmetric
function is that more understandable
I'm about to give I'm going to give
another example
on all right
so we're going to say that uh the
generating
function
uh
DF of some f in my non-commuting algebra
U is uh defined as follows
um
so so let's say well so I'm going to
Define
uh is where D is the map uh from my
non-commuting algebra U to the
polinomial ring
uh which just takes
W and sends it to this quasy symmetric
function so I just extend this map
linearly so I have some I have some
words okay I have some sum of words in
my algebra U for each word I look at its
descent set and I build a corresponding
quasy symmetric function and then I sum
them up that's what this generating
function is so for example
uh let's take D of
um the following sum of um
words in a can equivalence
class okay so this is this is one of the
components in your in your handout so
the second to top
one 234 2314
one some con equivalence class so so
what does um what uh what does this D do
so um I need to compute The Descent sets
of each of these words right so here uh
two is bigger than one so there's a a
descent there right uh but here one to
three that's increasing 3 to four is
increasing so for this word I get my
quasi symmetric function of just set
one one records where that descent
is Plus what's the next one so there's
no descent from 2 to 3 there's a descent
from 3: 1 no descent at one to
four this giv me Q sub 2 of
x uh and then lastly no descent from 2
to 3 no descent from 3 to 4 and there's
a descent from 4 to
so that's the third index and I get
this so this is a sum of uh some quasy
symmetric functions whose definition is
a little weird but any guesses as to
what this sum
is so I claim that it's actually a
symmetric
function and and it's one you may know
about so so this is the symmetric
function which which is the sure
function of shape
31 so these these quasy symmetric
functions are convenient building blocks
for sure
functions so how would you have known it
was 31 without doing going through the
whole calculation and then seeing at the
end of the day
31 course or we we will prove it well or
not prove it but we'll it will be a
consequence of some theorems that I'm
going to write
down follow from this representation
function no no
um
so
um if you if you want want to think of
it in terms of representation theory of
the general linear group you can think
of um each of these words is
representing something in the zero
weight space and it sort of repr it it
it represents
uh you could say all of the
semi-standard young Tableau who
standardize uh to a certain Tableau
actually it would probably be the
recording Tableau of each of these and
and then and then when you sum up over
all those semi-standard young tuo that
would give you the character of uh the
whole the whole S31 you write it out
what S31 is so that you can check oh so
do you mean what it is do you mean in
terms of semi standard young t
or
um
uh is this is this what you had in
mind I it's not such an explicit
formula write down
WR so many
terms but but there are infinitely many
semi-standard young tblo that's the
problem I mean so these are infinite
this is an infinite sum okay so but see
it gets grouped there's a natural way to
group these right so you can you can
group them as like one one one two this
would be
um this would standardize to uh 1 2 3
4 okay whereas some Tableau like uh some
semi standard young tblo one 1 2 4 would
stand standardized to 1 2 3
4 so under this standard there's only
three Tableau sem there's only three
standard young Tableau of this shape
okay each semi-standard young Tableau in
infinitely many variables will still all
will standardize to one of them and that
decomposition of the sh function is the
same as this one into quasi symmetric
function uh
that okay I there was a bunch of other
stuff I
mean but don't understand the arrow with
the St uh okay so this
um so the standardization
map uh
okay you're you're okay okay so what you
do is you you think of uh like all the
ones you replace them by 1 2 3 4 5 from
left to right and then all the twos you
replace those by the next uh letters
increasing there will be a
third yes that's right so
one
uh and for instance you know one two two
would standardize to this
yes you can actually make this
completely explicit with a basis and so
on
yeah so now um now I'm going to tell you
about uh
non-commutative uh symmetric function so
first we'll start
with um non-commutative Elementary
symmetric
functions
so this uh is Ed of uh
U is defined in the following way so
um the
sum over
ui1 so basically it's a sum over
decreasing words of length D okay so
this is this is some non-commutative
version of Elementary symmetric
function so we had a choice as to how to
define this we want the the goal was to
produce some Elementary symmetric
function so that when we when we pass to
the commutative quotient then it
actually gives us the Ordinary
Elementary symmetric fun so we could
really choose any order we like here but
somehow this is the right
choice right so so now uh we can Define
the non-commutative sh
functions all right so we're going to
we're going to be working in a setting
in settings where so quotients of U
where these Ed these non-commutative
Elementary symmetric functions commute
with each other all right and when they
commute with each other that means they
generate an algebra that's isomorphic to
the ordinary ring of symmetric functions
so that's that's just the polinomial
ring in the EI what what will they not
commute with h if they commute with each
other what are they not allowed to
commute with well I mean for instance
they will not commute with like
U1 so if you multiply U1 but if you
multiply U1 by that I mean if you want
to stay in the ring of symmetric
functions or you're going to allow
believe that I mean we're not we're not
in ring symmetric functions at all
because this this lives in this lives in
this non-commutative world okay are you
claing they commute with each other edu
with e Fu whatever they commute no no
but but we will state a theorem that
starts with that assumption um and but
but I'm just sort of prefacing this
definition so
um so basically we're going to Define
these non-commutative sh function using
the Jacobi Trudy
formula uh
so um in fact if you like I
can I can maybe I can write down the
theorem before I write down the
definition of
j that will help
but so here's the
theorem
um which says that
if uh the
E you
commute in um some quotient of
U
then uh the generating function of some
f is given by the
following is over partitions
Lambda uh this is
provided for
any fni I
per so what is this what is this saying
so so I take some some f so this this I
per is subset of
U uh I take some f in the orthog Al
complement of I under the inner product
in which the words form an orthonormal
basis okay so so I'm making some special
choice of inner product here which is
actually important right uh and I choose
this F in this orthogonal complement
then the generating function of f as in
this definition up here which we got so
so here's was one of the examples and
this generating function is well it's
actually
symmetric and it's sure expansion is
given by taking taking inner products of
f with uh this certain non-commutative
Shure function that I'm about to
Define it's a it's a weird it's it's a
weird thing to see at first um but
actually this is not this is not a very
deep result okay so this is kind of just
translating some language it follows
from from facts about uh ordinary
commuting uh ordinary symmetric
functions in commuting
variables
will by
commutator no it's any um sorry sorry
sorry uh for
some two-sided ideal I but there's a
minimal ideal you can construct just
from
all that's right you you could so why
why are we keeping ey mysterious uh
that's a yeah you'll you'll see there's
there's something else that you need to
do for this to be
useful okay that's not true for that in
that General set you're going to take a
slightly larger eye yes that's right but
actually that's a very good question um
and one of the things that I've worked
on with uh s fine is explicitly
understanding that eye and and we do
actually
um so so let me Define these J lambdas
for you so this J
Lambda of U is going to be uh the
determinant okay so here Lambda is a
partition of Lambda Prime
I
um
Plus
what okay so this is um some determinant
of some non-commutative things so let me
write out finding your deter yeah I'll
write out explicitly how we can Define
it so uh we can Define it as uh just
this
product
T is equal
to so this is
uh
okay thank
you okay so we just chose an order for
the product of these e okay this Lambda
Prime is the conjugate of
Lambda but in in this theorem it doesn't
matter what order we chose right does
this determine and obey the Kramer's
rule
uh ring so you have to order determinant
each of the moners by R yeah but there's
this like red talk G on red talk or red
talk sort of ay determin calls that is
rigged so cramers will work
this can chose a yeah I mean in the
settings that we're interested in it's
it doesn't end up mattering but there
actually are some things I've studied
here are actually flag versions of this
in which case it does really matter
which uh Direction you choose in and
there are some you know nice properties
that that determin it still satisfi I'm
not sure if that's one of them um so in
the compu setting the
first yes that's right yeah so this is
this is some this is just jobi try
basically
okay so this this theorem that I just
stated this is this is kind of just
changing some language but now the um
the theorem I'm about to state is really
the Deep part and what what makes this
uh you know interesting
so
um uh let's see
um so in in a certain
um quotient of You by these fomine green
relations so this is in figure two of
your your hand out under this foaming
green relations I don't want to I'm not
going to say too much about these
relations yet but I'll just say for now
that they're very weak relations so
many so this implies sort of many things
because these are such weak relations so
if if this thing that I'm about to write
down uh is
true so J lamb U is the
sum um over standard young
Tableau Lambda of the column
word okay so here column word let me
just do an example of some
Tableau is just what you get by um
reading the columns from bottom to top
and then left to right so this is 631 4
2 5
so so this is a sum over um column
reading words of of these Tableau in
these non-commuting variables okay and
and the statement is this that this
holds in this in this algebra with very
weak relations it does not hold in in
the most General algebra you can take
that's that's sort of the answer to your
question all right but it's it holds in
this this algebra that's that has weaker
relations than platic algebra okay so it
in fact implies that this is true inside
the platic
algebra right and so now now let's see
what what you can do with
this uh okay so so let me give so now
I'm going to give sort of three
applications
um the first is maybe not quite an
application but is kind of a think of as
a diagnostic test that that everything
is working the way it should be so we're
going to let
um
so we're going to let I equal uh the
defining ideal of the platic algebra
two-sided ideal uh corresponding to
those relations I wrote down before
those are on your sheet in figure two
and we'll let um
f uh be some of words in
some
uh equivalence class okay uh so here T
is some semi-standard young
Tempo and note that
f um I'm not going to prove this for you
but the the sum of of the words in a can
the equivalence class uh lies in this
orthogonal complement
of Ideal okay and this such such sums
form a basis actually for for this
orthogonal
complement the the same statement will
be true anytime you have the quo of view
by binomial
relation does this mean
standard of shape of shape mu this
is is some
partition this this uh living in this
iurp is some kind of
unintuitive condition but it's it's sort
of a natural generalization of a sum of
words in an equivalence class that's
that's how you should think of
it
um and then this generating
function is the sum s Lambda X so I'm
just copying from over
here uh this inner
product okay and then this this
non-commutative sure function is equal
to the sum of column reading words okay
so I'm using these two theorems here to
compute this and and now what is this
inner product well it looks sort of
weird but if I have on the left is just
going to be some sum of words of in some
set okay so that is the coefficients of
all these uh of all the monomials here
are just zero or one
and same thing for f so basically I just
have two sets and I'm going to intersect
them uh and count the cardinality of
that intersection that's what this inner
product
is so then the question becomes for this
specific case I have uh the column
reading words of shape Lambda and I want
to know how many of them lie in some
fixed can equivalence class of uh
corresponding to a tableau of shape
mu this bilinear map so distinct noncom
monom areal or what yes the the inner
product is where just yeah just
monomials are are in orthonormal basis
right so that that's why this this inner
product is just the size of the
intersection of these two sets okay and
so this is just this is just s mu of X
okay because there's exactly one column
reading word inside each can equivalence
class we know that from the rsk
algorithm for
instance and
so uh so it has to be of um of shape mu
for uh for this to be one otherwise
there's no
intersection okay and this this recovers
sort of
um result of
gule in some sense this this equal that
this sum of quasy symmetric functions
over a c equivalence class is equal to
the sure function this is kind of one of
the reasons one of the reasons that
these quasy symmetric functions were
defined so this this well if we believe
these theorems this proves this this
example that we had before the sum of
quasy symmetric functions is a sure
function so we think of these Cony
equivalence classes that sort of maybe
are kind of basic building blocks for
building sure functions
so the next
example next application
yeah out of out of time okay okay um all
right so if you if you look at
um uh figure
three uh then this is another kind of
equivalence class um
for an algebra called the nil coxer
algebra okay so uh the nil coxer
relations these are on the the front
side of the sheet this is it's basically
like the relations for the symmetric
group except instead of saying si^ 2al 1
you say s i^ s equal 0
okay and and these um these equivalence
classes the the corresponding symmetric
functions you get here are what are
called Stanley symmetric functions or
stable Schubert
polinomial okay so in in 1987 Stanley
made a conjecture that these things were
sure
positive um and then I think several
years later uh Edelman and green proved
this using something called coxer C in
insertion okay so so this took a
significant amount of work developing
this different kind of insertion
algorithm but with this framework you
kind of get you get it for free actually
I mean this this is the hard theem
actually so it's not for free but you
have to prove this and then the rest of
it comes for free and it basically says
you look at this this uh equivalence
class in the Neil coxer algebra and you
read off the words that are column
reading words and that tells you the
sure expansion of this uh Stanley
symmetric
function so I'll end there thank
you questions
coms so you're able to obtain some new
results using these techniques
uh green that's the uh third application
I was going to tell you though uh so
there's um there's a result for what are
called three column McDonald
pols uh that comes out of this um so so
other there's a QT version of of Costa
coefficients that has been pretty
intensively studied since around 1990
and so this gives sort of one case
beyond what was
known so this positivity refer to what
you explained about the positivity also
also about the ti of
your that were was shown using this
theor so positivity of what
exact so positivity of the sure
expansions of these things
the
DF of these generating functions that
arise from these graphs expansion in the
basis of on the basis of sure functions
but this means this in the
product so okay so the the which
something I didn't really get time to
explain is is the key to to making this
approach work is that you have to write
this non-commutative sh function as a
positive sum of in your algebra which
was done in this case by fan green but
in other cases it's it's hard or not
true and and that's the products be zero
or positive or positive yeah always I
mean always one so so essentially the
approach reduces everything to this
showing that this J Lambda is is some
non- negative sum of
monomials so some computation in this
non-commutative
algebra which is a hard comput
but but it somehow organizes the work
for
you no more
questions
than that is it tomorrow
again
a